[Music]
this morning we continue our special
series that we call kindness 101. i like
that title with one of our favorite
storytellers steve hartman so we all
know steve from his on the road it's
emmy-winning series for the cbs evening
news and now he shares the stories that
are built around the themes of kindness
and character and the people who have
mastered those qualities it's a good
topic of discussion for kids but we also
believe that adults will learn a thing
or two as well in this lesson today's
lesson is the e word empathy steve and
his son and daughter introduce us to a
selfless little boy whose favorite thing
to do favorite thing to do helping
others
good morning i'm here with my daughter
meryl hi and today we're going to
explore empathy what is empathy for that
we go over to your brother emmett at the
dictionary desk emmett so empathy is to
experience the thoughts or feelings of
someone else yeah or the ability to look
at what someone else is going through
and say what if that was me
this is a very important quality because
without empathy people wouldn't care
enough to help each other it would be
like
hey you handled that yourself it's
exactly right it's hard to imagine well
fortunately america is full of empaths
those are empathetic people
and i have an example to illustrate a
story pulled from our archives about a
preschooler who is so empathetic
it's his superpower
[Music]
he's faster than a speeding stroller
more adorable than a wet kitten and able
to get a stranger's attention with a
single courtesy excuse me this is
america's latest superhero don't forget
to show love and the only superhero with
the power to feed the homeless
now why do you do that you know what mr
c it's just the right thing to do is it
yes
you want honey by day austin perrine is
a mild-mannered four-year-old from
birmingham alabama but about once a week
he turns into this alter ego would you
like a sandwich a superhero set on
feeding as many homeless people as
possible thank you what's your superhero
name president austin president austin
president of president austin that's his
idea of what the president is supposed
to do
i was like buddy you have no idea
but hey i'm going along with it tj says
this all began when they were watching a
tv show about pandas it showed a mama
panda abandoning a baby tj told his son
the cub was now homeless
he says what's homeless i said well it's
when you don't have a home and sometimes
you don't have mom or dad around i can
tell what the follow-up question is
going to be yeah are people homeless
when i was a four-year-old i didn't care
about helping people
i did
i see
once austin learned some people are
homeless and some are even hungry he
launched this caped crusade told his mom
and dad that he wanted all his allowance
and money they would spend on toys
to go toward chicken sandwiches instead
oh thank you baby you're welcome don't
forget to show up
after he gives out each sandwich he
gives each person that same bit of
advice don't forget to show up
don't forget to show love he tells them
and most do
immediately why thank you
it was my heart to see you it didn't
warm anyone's heart yeah he really did
man
raymont boss says this kid gives him
hope that's that's where it starts don't
forget to show love everyone who meets
austin leaves with hope
which is why with any luck someday
president austin won't be a superhero
anymore
being the homeless is the highlight of
my life
he'll just be
a president all right come on austin
superhero and announced 2052
presidential candidate austin pearin
joins us now hello austin hey tj
hello hello do you still feed homeless
people
yes i do it once a week you still wear
the cape
no because
i was getting like too much attention
everyone was noticing me and i wanted to
be more about the homeless people
tj did you raise them to be like this or
is this just coincidence well it's a
combination of both i try to do the best
i can but i'm a lucky guy as well it's
just something that i love to do it's
like my passion i gotta feed them you
know
what are you thinking
everything
you just made my daughter get emotional
no but i think everybody feels the same
thing it's okay
no we just think you're a really sweet
young man and we're glad you're out
there helping people feeding the
homeless is still the highlight of my
life
beautiful
well thank you very much for joining us
you too we really appreciate it thank
you
and meryl if you're empathetic you know
what i'm feeling now
happy that we did that story yes we'll
see you next time until then stay kind
gosh i'm with you meryl i wanted to fall
into steve's lap too oh president austin
amazing four years later he still has
that light and still is out there what
did he say feeding the homeless is the
highlight of my life the light of my
life what is it 20 52 his uh
presidential run he'll be eligible at
that point i i love his uh his catch
phrase as well don't forget the show
oh my gosh nice job president austin and
dad too
nicely done we invite you to share your
kindness 101 stories with your kids it
could be a nice after-school activity
and you can find all of these kindness
101 episodes on our website cbsnews.com
kindness 101. you can also find them on
our facebook page stories can't do
enough of these stories in my opinion
they give you the feels gail